and first at six o'clock heavy winds and
flooding tonight we are taking a closer
look at the aftermath from the storms
and those microbursts that ted was just
talking about
and a good friday evening to you thank
you for joining us on eight news now at
six i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the weather
yesterday is still the talk of the town
yeah madison kimbrough joining us live
at the henderson sports complex
they really had a whole lot of damage
right there madison
oh yes the damage is quite extensive
here let me show you take a look as you
can see
the netting is ripped in half the
fencing is down there are also down
trees even the scoreboard took a tumble
and tonight henderson residents recall
what they saw i had to sit in the
parking lot for half an hour
couldn't move you know and the the car
just shook
so it was it was bad henderson residents
recall how strong the weather was
thursday
knocking down power poles ripping
through fences and flooding several
areas across the valley
chris fucille was at work when the
weather came down hard
and he captured it all on camera those
monsoons come on like nothing
and we stepped outside and it was just
raining sideways
and there was just water everywhere i
mean i've been here 10 years
and i've seen the monsoons here every
summer but this was
unlike any other one i've seen i mean it
was blowing doors open
over at the henderson sports complex
park officials couldn't believe the
damage left behind
we basically have widespread damage
throughout all the parks not only
structural damage
to our scoreboard to our fences to our
netting to our bleachers but we have
damage to trees that have been here
almost 30
years city of henderson crews are now
cleaning up the trees and making sites
safe again
residents say thursday's weather was
definitely an experience to remember
with the water so powerful it easily
could have swept them away
that water is so powerful i mean it if i
were to have got my foot in there or
something that would have swept me off
my feet like nothing
now other than the damage we showed you
the metal bleachers here at this sports
complex
folded in half and these are metal
bleachers we're talking about
the weather yesterday was definitely
extensive and we're still hearing
rumbles
right up here as you just saw reporting
live madison kimbrough 8 news now